this is a production of Cornell
University and in my slides but I hope
I'm gonna convince you that in the trace
that we're looking at its we really want
to learn about concepts so let's just
get to it so I'm gonna so I'm going to
talk about the how we are trying to
uncover metabolic regulation of free and
bound amino acids I think here it's
really easy understand why we're doing
that we're eating we're actually eating
a lot of types of seed but not all seeds
are born equal as was mentioned here
about 70 percent up to 70 percent of
human food consumption can be basically
achieved from rice corn and wheat and
those are great as carbohydrate source
but they're very poor source of protein
I know some of you really want to they
are very poor source of protein and not
only the levels are low but also their
quality is low so what does it mean that
the quality is low when we look at the
amino acid composition in for example in
some of the cereals in the most epic
group they're actually insufficient to
meet our dietary requirement so this is
a table of the essential amino acid in
eat rice and maize and the unit's here
are sold in increased to get are
required dietary allowance per day I'm
gonna translate it and in red those are
area of concern let me translate what
we're seeing here so healthy he will
need to eat eight kilogram of wheat or
corne birthday to stay healthy it
doesn't eat any dairy or meat and that
does happen and also we need to
understand that our livestock so that's
we can work on that so let's try to
understand the mechanics of what we're
seeing so here are our dietary protein
when we eat we hydrolyze them to their
free amino acid pool and then we are
assemble our own body so let's imagine
that we don't have this yellow break
enough to build our own body protein so
more and more of course excrete excrete
more and more in order to gain what you
need so these are where these numbers
are coming from so here if we can
rebalance the dieters and get corn to be
in a composition of a steak we will be
able to eat far less right because no
matter how much you love this kind of
excessive so I will briefly go over what
people have tried to do so this was a
problem that has been addressed by Brian
Larkins and since then and there are a
lot of problems to improve that
composition and this is where I hope my
lab comes in but before I'm gonna let
you see a little bit about what we're
doing I want to introduce you to the two
functional amino acid pool in the scene
so we have five percent free very small
but it's very important because the
feeling of acid are basically the
precursor for proteins but they're also
the precursor of many other metabolic
processes like awesome alight TCA cycle
they can go into secondary metabolites
so they are very important and then the
remaining 95% are actually deposit in
the probe so FA a will be from now on
PBIA so we have 95 around 95 percent in
the protein bound amino acid depends on
the species and up to 70 percent will be
depositing what we call seed storage
proteins
and those are actually the main culprit
because those seed storage protein are
very poor in those essential amino acid
and again I don't think I mentioned
those essential amino acid our amino
acid that we have to take from our diet
and we cannot synthesize in our body so
the storage protein are really very
highly abundant but they are very poor
in essential amino acid so we have a way
out right so researcher what basically
researchers have thought about is we can
knock those all out right they're very
problematic let's just get rid of them
brute force but it appeared to be that
when we do that and knock them all out
even though they can represent a major
chunk of the proteomics thing you
actually see very have what they have
shown that we have free amino acid
reprogramming and even more importantly
rebalance so it turns out that all these
amino acid are just going elsewhere and
we do not get what we want
so another approach is just to but it
turns out the same phenomena this
protein bound amino acid rebalancing how
this rebalancing is actually what is the
mechanism is actually not know why is it
even there it is not known we can
postulate but we'll talk about it a
little bit later so finally another
approach that people have been trying to
do is right it's really wanted or the
precursor for protein if we're going to
further on with those of the dry seed
but that turned out to be also not super
successful we can increase the level of
protein by increasing the free amino
acid flow in to the protein but mostly
we cannot change a lot regarding the
composition actually the only amino acid
that if you increased and change some of
the
composition is methionine so and this is
where kind of I think my lab is coming
in so the conclusion is that we don't
know a lot and in order to improve
understand really basic question about
basically regulation so in my lab we're
focusing on two main question how do you
plant regulate amino acid level and
composition those are actually
disconnected and how do they control
seed amino acid composition in response
to a biotic stress so regulation is with
everything is going right controlling
when everything is going wrong um so I
hope time will allow I will show you
today first of all kind of to do some
basic under star basically understanding
what is the effect of water stress on
these trade in dry areas and again we're
doing that because we think it's very
translatable this rebalancing mechanism
is happening in corn and soybean crops
is almost every species that we look at
is doing this rebalancing mechanism and
then I'm gonna talk about how we harness
natural variation in order to get to the
bottom of the genetic basis of this
trait and then trying to figure out if
the interplay can teach us even more
about how we can go about
biofortification of these traits but
before we start every experiment today
nowadays is very extensive we needed a
high throughput analysis so fortunately
as was mentioned i'm coming from dean de
la feni's lab so there during my postdoc
i further develop that is based on LC
ms/ms mrm reaction monitoring approach
basically targeted approach to detect 24
genic amino acid this method was
established by the Dan Jones
what's really great about that you can
measure absolute levels very short time
span with great resolution
I know there are NIR methods here but
they're not to look at very small
changes or natural variation changes for
some amino acids they are and it's only
96 set up and are semi-automatic so you
can see here the total ion count and
when we look at the channel you can see
that we can really resolve beautifully
those three amino acids so great we have
an affordable which is the key point
here and really short method to check
our free amino acid but the problem that
we did not have I think one of the
problems that really embed the field a
lot of genomic analysis on Association
panels in order and in order to do that
we had to have a very simple method so
we thought great that's very simple
we're just gonna wish HCl I draw a blue
oh we had to work about a year to
actually make it happen but we finally
succeeded and now we have what we call a
micro scale HCl hydrolysis you actually
need only two to three milligram in
order to detect 15 protein bound amino
acid that represents seven but we do
want high throughput method it's all in
96 place setup and it is compatible with
our three amino acid analysis so now we
have a very affordable way to look at
those traits in however we want again
the previous ways are were either
lengthy expensive or needed a lot of
materials and working with those or AB
adapters and maize or some mutants that
we are
don't have a lot of sample for was kind
of a problem so this is actually
publishing current protocol in plant
biology if you're interested in this
method so now we decided to start with
something super simple just water stress
on both free and bound amino acid and we
also wanted to look whether intensity or
duration influence and this is because
they can function as life or they can be
it can be the result of protein turnover
we also know from weeks that the
proteomic composition is changing when
there are drought periods however we
don't know if this rebalancing mechanism
is happening or not so in order to start
kind of teasing apart what's going on
there doctoral buyo be implemented
another set up two sets of experiment
one water limitation and the other water
deprivation and we were interested in
understanding what's happening during
setting so all our treatments so in the
water limitation we had 100% capacity
seventy five fifty five and ten capacity
and in our water deprivation basically
those treatments we had again from one
week after bolting we irrigated for one
week two weeks three weeks in our growth
conditions and when we look I don't show
it but when we look at relative water
content in the soil we see that we're
reaching our targeted capacity very
quickly as well when we are applying
water deprivation and after all right so
before we are going to talk about the
found amino acid we just first of all
went a little bit about key
physiological traits that are going to
be super relevant so we looked at CEO
then we looked at seed weight the
wingman
limitation no surprise there we lost a
lot of yield up to 70% and he started
all the way from 50% odd capacity in
water limitation when we looked at
actually seed weight we actually see an
increase so milder water stress in our
OB Dobbs's actually caused again from
50% for capacity and increase in weight
and decrease in seed yield when we look
at water deprivation we are seeing a
much larger reduction in yield up to 90%
and we see a reduction in the weight
so at least in our OB DOCSIS I know that
it's not only in Arabidopsis we have a
plastic response of the weight of the
water stress but again what we were
really interested is trying to
understand what's happening or you know
for our three and bound amino acid so
first I'm going to show you the total
free amino acid and the total bound
amino acid so in water limitation what
we have seen that from 25% and on three
amino acid went up and they were pretty
much coordinated with what happened in
the total bound amino acid so again from
25 well I need to mention that so we are
normalizing first thing right we are
interested in per biological unit so
this is mostly due to increasing seed
size what we're looking here is the
water deprivation you can see that from
basically three weeks so three weeks of
water deprivation we have a very large
free amino acid they just jump so it's
kind of showing some sort of metabolic
switch and when we look at the total
bound I mean nothing really happens but
I just thought you know either
really reducing about 23% of their
weight so we went and looked at the seed
nitrogen and seed carbon to understand
what's going on so in water limitation
we can see really that just in the 10%
we have elevation
carbon and nitrogen so the 25% wood size
and in water deprivation and this is
unit of percentages we have increase in
nitrogen but we don't really have
increasing or decreasing so why they're
decreasing because the percentage of
carbon remains the same absolute level
it is reducing so very different
metabolic responses that are giving
essentially the same effect increase in
the nitrogen in both water deprivation
and limitation but underlying molecular
mechanism are different so we wanted to
see it individual amino acid are
actually making any specific
contribution again looking at the water
limitation and this is in fold increase
in fold decrease we first we can see
that here these are the free amino acid
they're kind of mostly elevated in
coordinates all of them in coordinates
with our water deprivation with our
water treatment but when we look at what
are the privation we can see that not
all of them are kind of and this is
really consistent with what we're seeing
vegetative tissue and also alludes to
the fact that we have an adjustment that
we do not have when we do water
limitation even though water limitation
is severe and percent capacity the
entire duration of the seed setting so
then one other thing we wanted to look
is their relative composition because it
seems that relative composition is going
to play an important part is from the
plant perspective so when we look at
water limitation these dyes are bigger
we have more nitrogen we have more
carbon but their relative composition is
actually
almost intact there a little bit of
change but really it's the same so again
this is in percentages this is now the
relative composition when we look at
water deprivation also changing
basically reprogramming of free amino
acid accumulation in seeds in dry seed
all these measurements are in dry seeds
so then we go to the protein bound amino
acid and again let's look for some
absolute level we see the same thing
that we've seen in the free amino acid
they're all seeds so most of it but
really again interestingly when we look
at the composition in both treatments
but again it's staining tact but
underlying mechanism that's going on
there is actually really different again
this water deprivation plans a really
miserable so how can we get the same
composition and again here seed sizing
is increasing here seed size is
decreasing what's going on there so in
order to start to answer this question
and what we discovered that when we
compare equal amount of protein between
the control and our treatment again
eluding that the acclamation we
basically went all the way to the
protein so we have just bigger seed and
we have more of what we had before but
when we look at the water deprivation
that we don't see any change in the
level of protein but amino acid we
actually see that 576 protein not genes
were significantly altered actually 541
well only 35 decrease so that was
interesting because again they overall
we see that nothing had changed so when
we look at the go enrichment analysis of
what are the three things that are
changing there is no surprise there
they're mostly
regarding biosynthetic processes or
processes related to this really very
intense water stress that we are
imposing on them but what was really
interesting was what was decreasing and
what was decreasing is actually those
highly abundant storage all three
storage protein that we know of from
Arabidopsis or actually going
significantly down and that was probably
enough at least from our data to
counteract this increase so I think if
we can conclude what we're seeing from
this first part is that we are seeing
proteomic rebalancing under water stress
and we are hypothesizing that this is
the origin of this rebalancing
rebalancing mechanism to begin with
providing that what we've seen that the
protein amino acid composition is
actually really rigorously maintained so
the conclusion from here we're really
profound in order for us to go and start
doing genomic data
what genomic studies and genomic
research approaches because we concede
it first of all free and bound amino
acid level and composition do depend on
stress in position but that's not a
surprise we also see that the
composition and the level are really
regulated differently so we can get
different things and they will be not
overlapping in their metabolic
regulation and that protein amino acid
composition is rigorously maintained but
under different molecular mechanism in
those slightly different well not
slightly in those different order in
position
that free amino-acids seems to be very
plastic adaptable traits and this is
consistent with what we know of them and
the protein bound amino acid which again
I remind you are the products are really
extremely robust traits that is very
hard to protrude so it seems that all is
lost but not really because when we look
at natural variation we do have natural
variation in these traits so it means
that we have a set point for those
compositional traits and that set point
is changed somehow
throughout evolution so I'm gonna show
you some of this data and we're gonna
we're gonna look at Mays first and then
maybe jump back if you have time to
arabi Dobbs is to see what are some of
those genetic basis potentially can be
and also talk about the interaction
between three and boundary lines so here
in this crowd I don't need to tell you
what is the Goodman diversity panel so
they've extras that took the corn
diversity panel Jerry Flynn Garcia was
gracious to give us 207 line that she
grew and first of all we wanted to
understand what is the natural variation
on this tree and as you can see free
amino acids are really much more
variable and protein bound amino acid
and again this is consistent with what
we're seeing but we also it means again
when one of the other question we wanted
to address is whether so we looked at
water stress but throughout natural
variation whether there is any
coordination between free and bound
amino acid so we did network correlation
analysis and we didn't enforce those
clusters so we had protein bound amino
acid really flustering separately from
the free amino acid consistent with
they're actually different function that
we just
seen in the water stress in position so
one of the before that so one of the
other thing we wanted to do is of course
look at the gene and the genetic
architecture or the genetic basis using
genome-wide Association mapping and see
if we get any any clues about the
interplay between them and again it is
important because remember that people
have thought it will bring more free
amino acid will actually affect the
proteins and what we are seeing is
actually that when in this specific
panel with a specific power that there
is no overlap between the candidate gene
and this is using G was we use farm CPU
I know I wouldn't say lakhs but I think
it's not as rigorous we use 5%
bonferroni all the way to 20% bonferroni
and we not only use the absolute level
of our trait because I just shown you
that their level and their composition
might be regulated differently so we
actually calculate one hundred and
thirty seven free amino acid traits from
their relative composition and from
biochemical ratio that we know of and
one hundred and six protein bound
I mean traits again based on our
biochemical knowledge and we have taken
100 KB from each side to deduce
candidate genes and still we didn't get
any overlap between them consistent with
the fact that they have different
function but again this is surprising
because they are basically precursor
end-product not gonna go very deep into
the genes that that underlying this but
what we don't see well let's start with
what we do see we see when we look at
three amino acid genes that are
involving translation energy and
degradation and when we look at the
protein bound G was and this is the work
that is ongoing genes that are related
to ribosomal protein vacuole ur sorting
and energy
if we kind of conclude what we're seeing
from this part is that it seems that the
genetic basis and the regulation of
those traits do not overlap so that
again if we translate it to breeding
that's super important because we can
take some approaches and not take others
and another thing and that is alluding
to what you don't see did not see genes
that are related to their metabolic
pathway and when we fade it you don't
have really the power but at least we
can say that they are not strongly
regulated by their metabolic power
metabolic pathways and then in the
protein bound amino acid we don't see
storage protein coming up and you would
expect that they would come up again
that's not the case and this is very
consistent with what we just seen with a
water stress so one also can say that
we're looking at the not the appropriate
kong point because we look at dry amino
acid right so we wanted to make sure
we're doing the right thing and we went
and looked at the development of the
seed and went and basically the
maturation all the way to the dry seeds
we looked at Ohio 43 and you can see C
average seed weight is going up and then
these are the total bound amino acid
you're going up well the free amino acid
is really kind of flatlining here like a
dead patient and we are not really sure
why it's going on so when we looked at
the individual amino acid you can see
this really coordinated up regulation of
their levels while free amino acid in
two separate line Ohio 43 and B 73
really they want over here again
consistent with probably their function
so I think I have ten minutes left so I
sorry so I would use it to try to answer
the question the following question of
what
what are they doing and what can they be
regulated by and one thing I do want to
add that the three amino acid in the dry
seas are actually very important for
germination I'm showing me that there
are consuming very rapidly during early
termination so it's not a useless
question so we're gonna jump really
quickly back to our bead OPS's and try
to see what is regulate what potentially
can regulate those traits so Marion
Emery an intern on in my lab have done a
really neat experiment blooming in the
dry seed in Arabidopsis so we used a 300
line Association panel we had three reps
and what we've done here is actually
take what we call a semi combinatorial
approach we took free glutamine and
arrived all the ratios for its metabolic
family which is the glutamate family
that is comprised of prolene glutamine
glutamate histidine is usually always
include we put it in anyway in arginine
we got thirty two traits but they're all
derivative traits glutamine in the dry
seat and what was nice usually we didn't
get any hits on absolute level of
glutamine or even the relative
composition of free glutamine and now we
got so one of the things that we wanted
to ask is whether we can associate it
with any other metabolic process in
order to do that and we took kind of a
rigorous cutoff we have a block analysis
and then we extracted all of those snips
that we're seeing for all history and
then we did a go enrichment analysis and
to our pleasant surprise we actually
found that we had an enrichment of the
glucosinolate pathway the glucosinolate
pathway is a secondary metabolic pathway
that is actually unique to Brassica and
it's auntie her livery
pathway and another thing is that those
three half the block with those three
genes a op13 and mom one are actually
known QTL that had been studied quite
thoroughly in the glucosinolates pathway
they are called the GS along and the GS
AOP excursion is that glucocil aids are
not related to free glutamine what what
are we seeing here actually the
aliphatic glucosinolate that the genes
that we had hits on came from starting
from the endo glucosinolate is starting
from tryptophan and the aromatic
glucosinolate is starting form so what
is happening here we were not sure as
really good researcher we started
knocking out all the genes that has to
do with Lucas in the late and in that
region I don't have time to show you but
we have three more focusing on a gene
that are in very strong LD with our
snips so we did those as well making
long story short we got really nothing
we were super discouraged we were also
very discouraged because when we did QTL
analysis on our trait in population that
we've seen and this is just an example
we actually seen relation over T was
straight so what happened what is
happening there of course I wouldn't
told you that if I had nothing so we're
getting to a point here so what we
decided to do is we decided that we
thought that our G was and our TTL
analysis is firm so how about we are
going to down-regulate and we can do
that by actually knocking out those
transcription factors that is regulating
and those are called me 29:28 and for as
a control we also looked at double
knockout of me 34 and 51
and this is controlling the in don't go
casino light so the sorry I have to say
that all the every time I show this
slide because it's my favorite side what
we've seen is actually something really
neat so the mid twenty eight twenty nine
we got a hundred which I know you're not
in the free amino acid business but I
have been doing this for ten years and
this is a lot so we were very very
pleased and also it's very very sick so
there are elevation but this is very
specific when we look at the mem 3451
it's actually you can see that nothing
is happening so that was really great
but then one day I was showing that and
Mark State came and say well so I had to
adjust that problem right so we got the
GTR one two double mutant which is
actually entered the seats and what
we've got is this beautiful green line
we also got thirty fold increase when we
did that control so it seems that there
is something very specific here that is
caused by the lack of the who personally
in the seed and I don't have the slide
to show it but we can turn to protonic
to try to understand even a little bit
more on what's happening there we
thought Budiman is very important for
nitrogen maybe all the amino coastal
amino acid is going down but that really
did not happen but what did happen so
again is coming up again but what did
happen that we got one of the most
highly abundant storage protein went
down by half so one of our hypothesis we
have to ongoing hypothesis that storage
protein are really high in glutamine and
proline naraba Dobbs's so maybe the lack
of incorporation to that is causing this
high glutamine again this is just a
knife offices
why all the rest of them are not going
as much it's not clear another
hypothesis is maybe the glutamine so
glucosinolate could be also a nitrogen
source maybe is replacing we don't know
we're still pursuing that but I hope I
convinced you that there is a connection
a metabolic connection that we attained
by doing she was between very specific
in the dry seed secondary metabolites
and the storage protein so why is that
interesting again when we are thinking
again about reading maybe those
connections they are very important role
in that so that is the conclusion of
part one I know we didn't answer those
questions but I hope I convinced you
that we are trying to understand better
the system and maybe what we're gonna
change things that we didn't expect so a
lot of people had done and they gene
approach and what were actually seeing
from our gia was that at least in
natural variation we don't see those
enzymes coming off as regulators
regulator has to do with secondary
metabolism I know people think of
secondary metabolism as a dead end but
those new secondary metabolites need to
come back to for metabolism somehow
right nobody
well not nobody but not a lot of people
are addressing this loop so maybe
through some of this genomic studies we
can we can look at that all right so
just acknowledging people that have done
a lot of the work of course everybody in
my lab and I introduced them and we have
some undergrad that are doing wonderful
job sherry that gave us the Mae seed 10
clip and Stan and Sam and of course
everybody else that we are collaborating
with and thank you for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
where are those amino acids are
incorporated yeah I need so this is why
we're cleaning this rebalancing because
I don't remember seeing any mineral
related there's not the one that
increased they're all over the place but
really the input there is response but
maybe including in those increases are
actually those proteins that needs to
again through this rebalancing mechanism
because as I said storage proteins they
really lacking some essential amino acid
so I I think there is a difference there
is a interplay there and I think what
another thing that I forgot to mention
so what I think my lab is going to try
to get at is what is the natural
of the rebalance I think we have a lot
about levels of amino acid but what we
really want to look at is the set point
and I have been talking to people and
trying to gather ideas how we can
mathematically represent that set point
in a good way so one way of doing Muji
was doing should't learning on PCs all
the way to 30 we are not we don't really
know I didn't show you we did some
genomic prediction analysis something in
the works we have consistent data that
show that actually the metabolic
pathways are not increasing our
prediction for our free amino acid data
and other that really fast they are
actually increasing our predictive
accuracy again this show it so multiple
ways we're seeing the same thing and
we'll try to develop the prediction
approach may be to inform us a little
bit more about how to look at this set
point but right now we're we're trying a
lot of things great question so we need
the midpoint so the question was do we
really think there is a direct
interaction between those transcription
factors I mean metabolism so we look
when we did this proteomic analysis we
look at enzymes level that has to do
with food I mean we are actually seeing
increase in the
mid 28 29 but we're not seeing an
increase in the gt-r 1 to Putin so I
think it is not glutamine metabolism and
because I don't think that those
mutation can actually alter the enzyme
function I don't think that but we can
we certainly need to check that I do
think that's what is happening is some
some source is kind of opening up in
glutamine is replenishing that either is
that I think what is really really
surprising for me was that only one of
the three highly abundant storage
protein very specifically was reduced
so one thing we might think of is trying
to get a direct interaction between
again those noobs and the storage
protein but then it leaves us again with
a transporter the MIBs are fine see that
protein so it almost seemed that that
the presence of the glucosinolate is
affecting very specifically a storage
protein there is superabundant ah you
guys have any idea what that mechanism
very puzzling but i think very exciting
this is not a lot of people think about
it right there there is no change in
their termination we didn't see look at
sitting establishment I can say that you
know that bigger seeds are better sees
usually we are doing this Germany we did
preliminary analysis we didn't see
anything we're now doing a much more
revised also because we know that some
elevation of free amino acid can
actually embed termination but that is
not happening this is why in the water
deprivation only specific family on acid
are increasing and those are
the one that are not effective that does
not have deleterious effect on
metabolism and again I think I started
to say it but mister but what I think
really important from this water stress
analysis that now we have another tool
to look at the balancing we can just do
multiple stresses right and what will
happen is my hypothesis is those that
this rebalancing will happen in
different shapes and form and then we'll
compare all those stresses we might
finally capture what evening the source
of this mechanism yeah that's that's I
think one of the big things that I am
taking away from within your face
diversity panel did you find any
patterns of tropical and temperate or
different lines so actually the answer
is mostly no no so this is for the bound
or the free in terms of the bound and
the free we did not fine
a lot of structure there we did do that
analysis and it seems that everything is
kind of everywhere we probably need to
go back to that but it's not strongly
those traits that's at what I can
definitely say
yeah but we are using that also for we
actually measured all these five types
of scene with its organ with it soybean
so in that protocol within many of them
but we can also do fresh tissue but we
we are we think the authorizing the
first issue is much better because then
you can normalize it for dried sea for
dry matter and I think that's a more
accurate way but it's very simple and I
think again I do believe this is was in
bending the field for a very long time I
know industry could have done that HP
and they have a lot of the information
but I think now we can this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu